bienvenido de nuevo a Quantum Computing in Practice, soy Olivia Lan y el episodio de hoy, el tercero, se va a centrar en un
experimento QAOA a escala de utilidad. Si has estado con nosotros desde el principio, nos has visto recorrer
el hardware cuántico de IBM, el marco de Qiskit patterns y las técnicas de mitigación de errores más recientes que
investigadores y desarrolladores usan para escalar los circuits cuánticos. Nos pareció realmente importante darte todo este
contexto y mostrarte la dirección que seguíamos, pero ahora ya no hay razón para esperar más y ver toda esta información en
acción. Antes de empezar, hay algunas cosas que tener en cuenta: todo va a seguir el marco de Qiskit
patterns, así que recorreremos estos pasos en orden. El primero es mapear el problema; el segundo, optimizar el circuit; el tercero,
ejecutar con Primitives; y el cuarto, el posprocesamiento o análisis de los resultados. Empezaremos con un ejemplo bastante pequeño
para que puedas entender bien estos pasos y su propósito. Luego hablaremos de un ejemplo muy similar pero mucho
más grande para mostrarte cómo se escalaría el problema al nivel de 100 qubits. Te voy a dar todas las
herramientas para que puedas avanzar después de esta clase y ejecutar ese problema de forma independiente. Por último, esto no va a
ser un recorrido por el código. Por más que lo intentemos, a medida que avanzamos el código envejece y queda obsoleto, así que si acabas
viendo este vídeo un año después de su lanzamiento, no quiero que te quedes atascado en la sintaxis que puede cambiar ligeramente con el tiempo. En cambio, esto será una
discusión detallada de la lógica y el planteamiento del problema. Sin embargo, hay un tutorial en notebook que acompaña a este
vídeo y está adjunto en la descripción más abajo. Seguir el código o consultarlo después de que
veas esta lección y ejecutarlo tú mismo te dará la mejor experiencia de aprendizaje posible. Así que, como recordatorio rápido,
no todos los problemas computacionales son adecuados para la computación cuántica. Los problemas fáciles y los cálculos simples no necesitan
aprovechar esta tecnología porque los ordenadores clásicos ya son perfectamente capaces de resolverlos. A partir de 2024, los
tres dominios sobre los que somos más optimistas son: la simulación de la naturaleza, el procesamiento de datos con
estructura compleja y, por último, la optimización. Los problemas de optimización son algunos de los
problemas computacionales más difíciles de resolver eficientemente. En un problema de optimización, buscas el valor más grande o más pequeño posible
para una función de coste determinada. Sin embargo, para muchos problemas de interés, encontrar ese extremo se vuelve exponencialmente más
difícil con el tamaño del problema. Por eso se vuelve tan complicado calcularlo. Como ejemplo, puedes imaginar lo
difícil que puede ser calcular las rutas de vuelo óptimas o las rutas de reparto por todo el país. En esta lección vamos
a explorar un problema de optimización concreto llamado Max Cut, que resolveremos usando un
algoritmo cuántico denominado algoritmo de optimización por aproximación cuántica, o QAOA. Entonces, ¿qué es el problema Max Cut? Un
problema de corte máximo es un tipo de problema de optimización combinatoria definido sobre un grafo, donde el objetivo es
dividir los vértices del grafo en dos subconjuntos de modo que el número de aristas entre los dos subconjuntos sea
máximo. Por ejemplo, en este grafo cada nodo está conectado de esta manera y el Max Cut se muestra con esta línea ondulada
que divide los nodos en el grupo morado y el grupo gris. La forma de hacerlo cruzando el mayor
número de aristas posible es cortar cinco aristas. Para este grafo, como es tan pequeño,
no es difícil probar unos pocos cortes posibles en papel o incluso mentalmente y darse cuenta de que cinco es la mejor opción
posible. Pero imagina que el número de nodos se duplicara y luego se triplicara: rápidamente esto se vuelve imposible de hacer a
mano, y a partir de cierto número se vuelve tan complicado que incluso los superordenadores tienen dificultades para devolver la mejor respuesta de forma fiable. Esto se debe a que
el número máximo de cortes escala exponencialmente con el número de nodos. Aunque esto pueda parecer algo abstracto,
existen muchos problemas del mundo real que pueden plantearse como un problema Max Cut, como la detección de fraude en finanzas,
la agrupación de grafos, el diseño de redes, el diseño VLSI e incluso el análisis de redes sociales. El de las
redes sociales es especialmente fácil de entender. Imagina que quieres encontrar un grupo de personas que tengan el mayor número posible de
conexiones con otras personas en una plataforma de redes sociales, con el fin de identificar usuarios influyentes o personas que tienen
la mayor influencia en un grupo. Las empresas intentan hacer esto con bastante frecuencia. Un último punto aquí: el Max Cut es a menudo
una subrutina de un problema mayor, por lo que puede que no defina la aplicación real, sino que se use internamente. Es
mucho más común de lo que podrías pensar a primera vista. Ahora es el momento de empezar. El
primer paso es crear nuestro grafo. Puedes hacerlo importando un paquete de Python llamado rustworkx. Define cuántos
nodos vas a usar especificando el número n; luego añade tus nodos al grafo G. También tendrás
que definir las aristas. Lo haremos a mano aquí, simplemente listándolas en un array como este, donde se indica el último
número que especifica el peso de la arista, es decir, con qué fuerza están conectados los dos nodos especificados. Aquí simplemente
usaremos un peso de uno para todos, aunque puede que disfrutes jugando con el peso más adelante y viendo cómo cambia la solución.
Para entender qué significa el peso en este contexto, volvamos a nuestro ejemplo de las redes sociales. Puedes pensar
en este peso como la influencia que una persona puede ejercer sobre otra. Tu conexión con tu cónyuge o familiar,
por ejemplo, probablemente tendría un peso mayor que alguien que es simplemente un conocido. Ahora dibuja tu grafo: el
tutorial adjunto te mostrará la sintaxis correcta. Antes de considerar cómo
mapear este problema en un circuit cuántico, construyamos algo de contexto sobre cómo el problema Max Cut se convierte en un problema de optimización
en primer lugar. Comenzamos por considerar la minimización de una función f(x), donde la entrada x es un
vector de dimensión n cuyos componentes corresponden a cada nodo del grafo. A esta función la llamaremos de ahora en adelante
nuestra función de coste. Luego necesitamos restringir cada uno de estos componentes a ser cero o
uno, es decir, a uno u otro lado del corte. Podemos escribir una función como
un par de nodos x_i y x_j, que nos dice si la arista correspondiente está en el corte. Así, la cantidad x_i + x_j
menos x_i·x_j indica si la arista está en el corte. Si esta cantidad es igual
a uno, implica que la arista está en el corte; de lo contrario, es cero y la arista no lo está. El problema de encontrar el
número máximo de aristas en el corte puede entonces formularse como la maximización de esta función. A continuación,
vamos a añadir un signo menos global a esta función, haciendo que el nuevo problema sea equivalente a encontrar el mínimo de esta función
en su lugar. Así, el mínimo de f(x) en este caso se dará cuando el número de aristas cruzadas por el corte sea
máximo. Elegimos plantear este problema como un problema de minimización porque esto nos permite después mapearlo sobre un problema de
minimización de energía, es decir, encontrar el estado fundamental, que es en lo que los ordenadores cuánticos son naturalmente muy buenos.
Pero recuerda que aquí todavía no hay nada relacionado con la computación cuántica. Aún necesitamos reformular este problema en
algo que un ordenador cuántico pueda entender. Ya estamos listos para ponernos manos a la obra y empezar el trabajo, y el
primer paso es mapear el problema en un circuit cuántico. Puede que no sea obvio cómo vamos
a pasar de un grafo como el que acabamos de dibujar a un circuit cuántico, pero vayamos despacio. Recuerda que estamos
vamos a intentar resolver este problema de corte máximo usando QAOA. En el algoritmo QAOA, en última instancia queremos tener un operador
el hamiltoniano que se usará para representar la función de costo de nuestro problema, así como un
circuit parametrizado, el ansatz o el estado de prueba que usaremos para representar estados cuánticos que son suposiciones educadas o candidatos
para la solución al problema. Podemos muestrear de estos estados candidatos y luego evaluarlos
usando la función de costo. En este caso la función de costo es f de x, pero necesitamos expresarla de una
manera que se sienta nativa para la computadora cuántica. Para esto, aprovecharemos una serie de transformaciones matemáticas
para expresar f de x como una función de energía, el hamiltoniano. El primer paso del
proceso es expresar el problema de minimizar f de x como una optimización binaria sin restricciones cuadrática
o QUBO para abreviar. QUBO es una forma general de formular estos problemas de optimización combinatoria.
Aquí Q es una matriz N por N de números reales. N corresponde al número de
nodos en nuestro grafo, cinco para este ejemplo, y X es el mismo vector de variables binarias de la
formulación inicial. Para ejecutar de forma efectiva el algoritmo QAOA, necesitamos expresar nuestro problema de optimización en términos de un
hamiltoniano, que es un operador matemático que representa la energía total de un sistema. Concretamente, queremos
crear un hamiltoniano de función de costo que tenga la propiedad de que su energía del estado base o valor propio mínimo
corresponda al mínimo de la función que codifica el número máximo de cortes en el grafo G. Una vez que
tengamos este hamiltoniano, todo lo que necesitamos hacer para resolver nuestro problema de optimización es preparar el estado base del hamiltoniano en la computadora cuántica; luego,
muestrear de este estado dará con alta probabilidad la solución a la minimización de f de X. Resulta que
tenemos suerte porque el problema QUBO está muy estrechamente relacionado con, y es de hecho computacionalmente equivalente a,
uno de los hamiltonianos más famosos y ubicuos en física: el hamiltoniano de Ising. Para escribir el problema QUBO
como este hamiltoniano de Ising, todo lo que realmente necesitamos hacer es un cambio de variable sencillo para pasar de
variables booleanas 0 y 1 a variables de espín menos uno y uno. Este paso es
directo. Se muestra con más detalle en el apéndice del notebook adjunto para quienes estén interesados, pero al final la minimización de esta expresión QUBO
es la misma que la minimización de esta expresión. Reescribiendo de nuevo ligeramente,
tenemos nuestro hamiltoniano de función de costo, donde el mínimo de la expresión representa el estado base, y Z
se convierte en el operador de Pauli Z, mientras que B es un coeficiente escalar real. Ahora que tenemos nuestro
hamiltoniano, es sencillo reescribirlo en términos de operadores ZZ de Pauli de dos cuerpos que se convertirán fácilmente en
dos gates cúbicas en nuestro quantum circuit. Consulta el notebook asociado para ver cómo se hace esto, pero la salida
está dada por esta línea de aquí. Nota que en nuestro ejemplo hay
seis objetos o cadenas de Pauli porque cada una representa una arista del grafo. La longitud de la cadena coincide con el número
de nodos, así que I I I ZZ son cinco nodos y la cadena estará compuesta de
identidades en todas las posiciones excepto en los índices de los nodos involucrados en una arista, que tendrán términos Z. En Qiskit,
las cadenas de bits que representan qubits están indexadas al revés. Por ejemplo, una arista entre los nodos 0 y 1 se codificará como
I I I ZZ. Con el hamiltoniano escrito en términos de Paulis, estamos listos para construir nuestro
quantum circuit. Este quantum circuit nos ayudará a muestrear buenas soluciones de la computadora cuántica. El algoritmo QAOA
está inspirado en el teorema adiabático, que establece que si empezamos en el estado base del hamiltoniano dependiente del tiempo
y si el hamiltoniano evoluciona lo suficientemente despacio y con suficiente tiempo, el estado final será el estado base
del hamiltoniano final. QAOA puede entenderse como la versión de Trotter discreta del algoritmo cuántico
adiabático, donde cada paso de Trotter representa una capa que llamaremos P. Así que,
en lugar de evolucionar de un estado a otro, en cada capa de P alternaremos entre nuestro
hamiltoniano de función de costo y algo llamado nuestro hamiltoniano mezclador, del que hablaremos más en un momento. Pero el punto que quiero destacar
es que QAOA tiene la ventaja de ser más rápido que el algoritmo cuántico adiabático, pero devuelve soluciones
aproximadas en lugar de las óptimas. En el límite en que el número de capas tiende a infinito, QAOA converge al caso
adiabático, pero por supuesto esto es computacionalmente muy costoso. Para crear nuestro quantum circuit,
aplicaremos operadores alternos parametrizados aquí por gamma y beta, que
representarán la discretización de la evolución temporal. Así que de nuevo, las tres partes principales
del qaoa circuit son: uno, el estado de prueba inicial en gris, que es el estado base
del mezclador a partir del estado adiabático de evolución, creado aplicando un Hadamard gate a cada qubit; dos,
la evolución de la función de costo, que ya tenemos en morado oscuro; y tres, la evolución bajo el
hamiltoniano mezclador, que aún no hemos discutido, en morado claro. Nuestro hamiltoniano inicial se
llama mezclador porque su estado base es la superposición de todas las cadenas de bits posibles de interés, lo que
impone una mezcla de todas las soluciones posibles al inicio. El hamiltoniano mezclador es la suma simple de operaciones de Pauli X
en cada nodo del grafo. Qiskit te permite usar un operador mezclador personalizado diferente si lo deseas, pero
para este caso vamos a usar el estándar. Así que de nuevo puedes ver que con Qiskit gran parte del trabajo
se hace por nosotros, haciendo que encontrar el hamiltoniano mezclador y el estado inicial sea trivial. El único trabajo que tuvimos que hacer fue
encontrar la función de costo. Cada iteración de estos operadores se llama capa. Estas capas pueden verse como
discretizaciones de la evolución temporal del sistema, como se describió anteriormente. El patrón alternado proviene de la
descomposición de Trotter y aproxima las funciones exponenciales de matrices no conmutativas. En general, cuantas más capas o
pasos incluyamos, más cerca estaremos de la evolución temporal continua, así que en teoría el resultado será más preciso.
Pero para este ejemplo empezaremos muestreando con dos capas. Recuerda que tanto el hamiltoniano de función de costo como
el mezclador están parametrizados. Todavía necesitamos encontrar los valores óptimos de gamma y
beta. Ahora reconozco que fue mucha información y si estás viendo este tipo de matemáticas por primera vez puede ser complicado. Por suerte, una de las cosas geniales
de Qiskit es que gran parte de lo que acabamos de ver puede hacerse automáticamente sin un gran esfuerzo por parte del usuario. Es bueno entender qué está
pasando bajo el capó, especialmente a medida que escalamos a experimentos más grandes, pero no tendrás que hacer todo este trabajo
manualmente cada vez. Ahora hemos mapeado nuestro problema en un quantum circuit. Fue un poco de trabajo,
pero no te preocupes, se vuelve más fácil e intuitivo cuanto más lo haces. Ahora estamos listos para pasar al paso dos:
optimizar nuestro circuit para el hardware. Así que aunque el circuit que acabamos de crear parece bastante simple y es
útil para construir una comprensión intuitiva, recuerda que el chip cuántico no entiende lo que es este bloque abstracto.
Necesitamos convertirlo en una serie de gates de uno y dos qubits que sean nativas del hardware, y cuando
cuando digo nativo me refiero a que será refactorizado en lo que puede ejecutarse directamente en los qubits; dichos circuits son
escritos en la arquitectura del conjunto de instrucciones del backend, que quizás hayas visto abreviada como ISA. Los circuits
el módulo transpiler del SDK de Qiskit ofrece una serie de pasadas de transpilación que pueden
realizar una amplia variedad de transformaciones de circuit. Queremos asegurarnos de que nuestro circuit esté optimizado para nuestro
propósito. Recuerda de nuestra lección anterior que el proceso de transpilación implica varios pasos: mapear los
qubits del circuit, es decir, las variables de decisión, a qubits físicos en el dispositivo; desenrollar las instrucciones del
quantum circuit a las instrucciones nativas del hardware que el backend realmente entiende; enrutar cualquier
qubit del circuit que interactúe directamente con qubits físicos que sean adyacentes entre sí
y, como siempre, más detalles al respecto se pueden encontrar en el sitio de
documentación. Ahora llega un paso emocionante en el que elegiremos qué backend usar para ejecutar nuestro circuit. En realidad tenemos que hacer esto
antes del paso de transpilación porque el transpiler optimiza de forma diferente para distintos procesadores. Esta es otra razón más por la que
es importante que Qiskit pueda automatizar gran parte de esta etapa. No querrías tener que optimizar tu circuit a mano,
lo cual se puede hacer, pero a veces es complicado y consume mucho tiempo, solo para darte cuenta de que en realidad quieres ejecutar
tu circuit en un procesador diferente con distintas propiedades y entonces tienes que hacer todo ese trabajo de nuevo. Pasa
el backend de tu elección a través de la función transpiler y no olvides especificar tu nivel de optimización. Esta
vez he seleccionado el nivel de optimización tres, que es el más alto y el más exhaustivo en cuanto a optimización,
y eso es todo para el paso dos. Mi circuit fue transpilado automáticamente y lo dibujé aquí para que
puedas ver cómo fue traducido a gates de uno y dos qubits. Ahora es momento del paso tres:
ejecutar el circuit con los Primitives de Qiskit. Hasta ahora hemos transpilado el circuit dejando los parámetros gamma y
beta sin modificar, pero no podemos ejecutar el circuit sin especificar el valor de estos parámetros. En el flujo de trabajo de
QAOA, los parámetros óptimos de QAOA se encuentran en un bucle de optimización iterativo donde ejecutamos una serie de
evaluaciones del circuit y usamos un optimizador clásico para encontrar los parámetros óptimos de beta y gamma. Sin embargo, necesitamos empezar
por algún lado, así que he implementado algunas estimaciones iniciales para gamma 1, gamma 2 y beta 1, beta 2 de Pi / 2 y Pi
respectivamente. También quiero que notes que usaremos un optimizador para encontrar mejores soluciones para gamma y beta.
Y como por ahora solo estoy calculando dos capas, eso es todo lo que necesito, pero si construyes un circuit QAOA más preciso
incluirías más capas y por lo tanto necesitarías un gamma y beta optimizados para cada capa
secuencial. Ahora tomemos un momento para pausar y recordar nuestras opciones para los Primitives: tenemos el estimator y
el sampler. ¿Cuál crees que vamos a usar para este tipo de tarea? Bueno, sin importar cuál hayas
adivinado, en realidad tienes razón: vamos a usar tanto el estimator como el sampler. Para la optimización
inicial necesitaremos el estimator, pero usaremos el sampler más adelante para leer la solución
final. Ahora casi estamos listos para ejecutar nuestro algoritmo, lo prometo, pero muy rápidamente es importante señalar que puedes
enviar tu trabajo de varias maneras distintas, que se denominan modos de ejecución. Primero tenemos el modo job: una única
solicitud de primitive al estimator o sampler realizada sin un context manager. Los circuits y las entradas se empaquetan como bloques
unificados de primitive (PUBs) y se envían como una tarea de ejecución en el ordenador
cuántico. El modo batch es un gestor de múltiples trabajos para ejecutar eficientemente un experimento que se compone de varios
trabajos independientes. Usa el modo batch para enviar múltiples trabajos de primitive simultáneamente. El modo session es una ventana dedicada
para ejecutar una carga de trabajo de múltiples trabajos. Esto permite a los usuarios premium experimentar con algoritmos variacionales de una manera más
predecible e incluso ejecutar múltiples experimentos simultáneamente, aprovechando el paralelismo de la
pila. Usa las sessions para flujos de trabajo iterativos y experimentos que requieren acceso dedicado. Para un experimento QAOA,
una session sería una buena elección si tienes acceso a ella, ya que necesitarás probar múltiples circuits con distintos valores de beta
y gamma. Bien, ahora volvamos a nuestro problema de optimización. Ya hemos
definido el hamiltoniano de función de costo HC y el flujo de trabajo completo es el siguiente: el algoritmo QAOA
comienza inicializando los qubits en el estado de superposición y luego aplica el CNOT con P capas;
inicializa los parámetros gamma y beta y luego ejecuta el circuit usando el primitive estimator. Una vez que calculamos
los valores de expectación, usaremos un optimizador de SciPy llamado COBYLA. COBYLA
optimiza la función de costo de forma clásica fuera de la QPU. Una vez que esos valores de gamma y beta han sido actualizados,
repetimos. Haremos esto hasta que el valor de la función de costo total haya convergido y alcanzado el valor más bajo.
Luego seleccionaremos los valores de gamma y beta que correspondan a este valor de bajo costo y ejecutaremos el circuit por última
vez, esta vez usando el sampler. Este es el resultado de ejecutar el optimizador COBYLA con mis estimaciones iniciales. Aquí puedes ver
que el valor de la función de costo a lo largo de las iteraciones realizadas empieza un poco errático, sube y baja, pero
luego se estabiliza en un valor bajo. Usaremos estos últimos valores de gamma y beta que corresponden al costo mínimo
para ejecutar el circuit por última vez y muestrear la cadena de bits que nos dará el corte
máximo. Ahora, usando nuestros valores optimizados para los gammas y betas, ejecutaremos el circuit por última vez para encontrar la mejor
cadena de bits posible usando el sampler. Aquí he listado los valores específicos que estoy usando, pero recuerda que cuando lo intentes
tú mismo o incluso simplemente vuelvas a ejecutar el mismo notebook del tutorial, estos valores podrían cambiar ligeramente. Ahora ejecutaremos
nuestro circuit optimizado con estos valores y encontraremos nuestra solución candidata al problema de Max Cut. Si estabas usando
sessions, ya no es necesario, ya que solo estamos ejecutando un último trabajo. Ahora finalmente veremos la etapa de
posprocesamiento y cómo encontrar nuestra solución final. Primero vamos a graficar todas
las combinaciones posibles de nodos, que hemos convertido en cadenas de bits, como un histograma. Puedes ver de inmediato que
cuando lo ejecuté encontré cuatro soluciones y resalté en morado las que son más probables que cualquier otra solución.
La cadena de bits más probable es 0 1 0 1. Por favor, ten en cuenta el orden de los qubits
que está invertido en la gráfica. Mirando la solución más probable, notamos que los nodos 0 y tres están agrupados
y de igual manera los nodos 1, 2 y cuatro. Finalmente podemos graficar la cadena de bits más probable
de vuelta como un grafo y recuerda que la cadena de bits simplemente corresponde a los números de los nodos y si están incluidos
marcados con un uno o no incluidos marcados con un cero en nuestro agrupamiento. Cuando dibujamos el corte ahora podemos ver a simple vista la
línea aproximada para el mejor corte, que simplemente representa el agrupamiento ideal de los cinco nodos, que he dibujado aquí. Una
cosa sobre la que quiero dedicar algo de tiempo aquí, sin embargo, es el hecho de que la solución correcta no es única.
Debido a la simetría de este grafo, hay múltiples soluciones correctas. En lugar de que los nodos 0 y tres sean
dentro del corte podríamos tener los nodos 2 y 4 incluidos, y puedes ver que todo lo que tuve que hacer fue rotar mi corte para
incluir estos nuevos puntos; la solución de cinco se mantiene igual
echemos otro vistazo al histograma y a las cuatro soluciones más probables por un momento; las últimas dos soluciones son las
que acabamos de graficar, y son igualmente correctas, pero eso no es todo: también podríamos invertir los colores de todas
las soluciones correctas, y esta vez simplemente pensamos en los nodos como estando dentro versus fuera del corte; en la
diapositiva anterior identificamos dos soluciones correctas únicas, pero en realidad hay dos soluciones más, una correspondiente a
lo opuesto a cada una de esas; fíjate que aquí, donde dibujé las dos soluciones restantes, todo lo que hice fue invertir los
colores; ahora bien, el único problema es que el algoritmo en realidad no encontró ni identificó esta cuarta última solución como
una de las cuatro respuestas más probables; fue la quinta; la cuarta solución que el algoritmo identificó
es en realidad incorrecta, y si la dibujaras verías que esa solución solo tiene cuatro cortes, y como las otras
tienen cinco, y cuatro es claramente menor que cinco, esto es obviamente incorrecto; el punto aquí
es que este es un algoritmo aproximado: no es infalible y no es correcto el 100% del tiempo; tienes que
aplicar tu propio conocimiento y comprensión para verificar las soluciones; vale la pena destacar que
este error puede surgir de varios lugares: podría ser la naturaleza aproximada del algoritmo en sí y el pequeño
número de capas que elegí usar; podría ser un error de muestreo finito, y esto se podría reducir si aumento el
número de shots en mi experimento, o podría ser un error de lectura, ya que la cuarta solución real solo difiere en un
bit; la razón por la que señalo todas estas posibilidades es porque esto es lo que se necesita para convertirte plenamente en un
practicante de la computación cuántica; necesitas entender el rendimiento del hardware y cómo esto puede contribuir
a ciertos tipos de errores y cómo corregirlos; sin embargo, no olvidemos que
había 32 posibles soluciones de cadenas de bits y que las cuatro soluciones reales estaban incluidas en los cinco
mejores candidatos, y solo usé dos capas para encontrar esto; en general, si quiero aumentar mis probabilidades de encontrar el
mejor Max cut cada vez, aumentaría la profundidad de las capas; hay algunas sutilezas en esto, pero eso es para un episodio posterior
ahora voy a dejarte que lo intentes tú mismo, pero esta vez vas a usar 100
qubits; así que si empezamos dibujando nuestro grafo de 100 qubits, puedes ver que ya no es sencillo ni siquiera posible
determinar a ojo dónde ocurriría el max cut; simplemente hay demasiadas posibilidades como para poder identificarlo a mano, pero
resolver este problema usando QAOA sigue siendo totalmente factible, y puedes seguir exactamente el mismo flujo de trabajo que usamos para 5
qubits; estoy a punto de enviarte a trabajar por tu cuenta y encargarte que intentes hacer este experimento, pero antes de hacerlo, hagamos un
resumen: recuerda que los seis pasos de cualquier trabajo con QAOA son los siguientes: uno, definir
un hamiltoniano de costo tal que su estado fundamental codifique la solución al problema de optimización; dos, definir un
hamiltoniano mezclador; tres, construir los operadores correspondientes a los
hamiltonianos exponenciados; cuatro, construir el circuit: consistirá en el estado fundamental inicial del mezclador y capas alternas
repetidas de la función de costo y la evolución bajo los hamiltonianos mezcladores; cinco, preparar un estado inicial y
usar técnicas de computación clásica para optimizar los parámetros; seis, ejecutar el circuit, medir las cadenas de bits de salida
buscando la solución más probable; ahora, hay algunas cosas a tener en cuenta:
usé el nivel de optimización tres para mi ejemplo de 5 qubits, pero quizás no era necesario, y la respuesta correcta podría
devolverse la mayoría de las veces con un nivel de optimización más bajo, porque la profundidad del circuit era bastante baja para el caso de 5
qubits; pero para los 100 qubits y una gran profundidad de circuit, casi con certeza necesitarás el nivel más alto de
optimización para encontrar la respuesta correcta; también ten en cuenta que una de las partes más desafiantes de un flujo de trabajo típico a escala de utilidad
es la etapa de mapeo, y encontrar un grafo que se corresponda bien con la topología heavy hex de IBM; si estuvieras
haciendo este trabajo desde cero, es indudablemente ahí donde dedicarías la mayor parte de tu tiempo; por ahora esta parte se ha
hecho por ti, porque ese no es el punto principal de este ejercicio, pero ten en cuenta que es algo que
requerirá práctica, y ejecutar un trabajo a gran escala no siempre es tan sencillo; profundizaremos en esto
más en el episodio 4; tu circuit final obviamente va a verse mucho más desordenado que el circuit que se ejecutó en 5 qubits
pero, por otro lado, siento que ver este circuit y ver cuántos gates tiene, y saber que
tienes la capacidad de ejecutarlo en procesadores cuánticos reales es bastante
impresionante; y esta fue mi solución final: puedes ver que el algoritmo es ciertamente capaz de agrupar estos
nodos en dos grupos, identificando supuestamente el mejor Max cut que los divide, pasando de los dos conjuntos
a la línea del max cut en sí es trivial: cualquier lugar donde el color cambia a lo largo de las líneas que conectan los nodos designa
dónde debe trazarse la línea del max cut; cuando lo ejecuté, el valor del max cut que pude alcanzar es
84; así que inténtalo tú mismo y dime en los comentarios si obtienes algo similar; prueba tres capas, quizás cuatro; prueba
cambiando los pesos entre los nodos y mira cómo eso cambia el resultado; hay muchos experimentos interesantes
que podemos ejecutar con QAOA; ahora recuerda que no está garantizado que haya encontrado la mejor solución posible
sabemos que es una buena solución, pero por diversión te desafío a intentar superarme: a ver si puedes obtener algo
mejor que 84; en conclusión, QAOA es un algoritmo muy dinámico
y hay muchas heurísticas y mucho por explorar todavía; deja mucho espacio para aprender cosas nuevas
sobre el campo de la optimización en general; ha habido mucho trabajo recientemente en el espacio de la optimización, como
lo evidencian todos los artículos en arXiv que se han publicado recientemente en línea sobre QAOA u optimización, y lo que es
realmente genial es que finalmente no todos estos artículos son artículos teóricos; los teóricos han estado trabajando y estudiando
QAOA durante años, pero ahora los experimentalistas se están involucrando porque finalmente tenemos el hardware
como los procesadores de IBM que son capaces de ejecutar muchos de estos experimentos; estamos pasando del espacio imaginativo
al mundo real, y eso es muy emocionante; sí, todavía hay mucho trabajo por hacer y todavía hay
muchos errores que necesitamos descubrir cómo manejar, pero estamos avanzando rápidamente, y tú, que estás viendo este
video y has llegado hasta aquí, eres capaz de ejecutar estos experimentos tú mismo; por favor ve a intentar ejecutar tu propio
experimento de 100 qubits y cuéntanos cómo te fue; sigue el tutorial y estarás en buenas manos, y si
tienes alguna pregunta o te quedas atascado, no te preocupes; todos nos sentimos así o tuvimos esas mismas preguntas cuando empezamos
a aprender esto; haz lo mejor que puedas, cuéntanos con qué preguntas te encuentras, y nos vemos la próxima vez
[Música]